Any Lord of the Rings fan knows that much of the movie was shot here in New Zealand,...
...but did you also know that you can actually visit one of the movie sets?
Today, we are headed off together to go visit Hobbiton, otherwise known as the Shire.
Let's go.
If you come on tour with us, you walk around with a knowledgeable guide.
There's 44 hobbit holes; no two hobbit holes are the same.
Thirty-three percent of all people who come on tour here have never read the books, never seen the movies,...
...but they still go away overwhelmed.
It's amazing! Every detail is taken care of.
If you look in the windows, you can see all the dishes and cups.
The great thing about this tour...
...is whether or not you know anything about Lord of the Rings,...
...it's a little fairy tale world that you can immerse yourself in.
The details are fantastic...
...and just the scenery is outstanding.
Oh my gosh! It's the one from the movie!
This is Bilbo Baggins' hobbit hole.